RATED TV SHOW FOLLOWING A TWEET
THAT MANY PEOPLE CONSIDERED
RACIST AND ALMOST ALL, INCLUDING
ABC, CONSIDERED OVER THE LINE.
AND AT MISSOURI REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR ERIC GREITENS, ONCE
CONSIDERED A RISING STAR IN THE
G.O.P. HAS JUST RESIGNED THIS
AFTERNOON I MADE AN IMPEACHMENT
EFFORT SPARKED BY A PAIR OF
SCANDALS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
COVERING HERE ON SPECIAL REPORT
FOR WEEKS.
FIRST, TO OUR MIDWEST NEWSROOM,
AND GOVERNOR GREITENS WAS MIRED
IN POLITICAL SCANDAL, AND IT WAS
AN ACTIVE SPECIAL SESSION IN THE
MISSOURI HOUSE TO CONSIDER
WHETHER GREITENS WAS GOING TO BE
THE FIRST GOVERNOR IN MISSOURI’S
HISTORY TO TEACH IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
HE WAS ALSO FACING A TRIAL AND
NOW A SHORT WHILE AGO THE
GOVERNOR FORMALLY ANNOUNCED HIS
RESIGNATION.
HOWEVER, THE GOVERNOR INSISTED
HE IS INNOCENT AND CHOSE CAREFUL
WORDS TO STRIKE BACK AT THOSE HE
BELIEVED WANTED TO TAKE HIM DOW
DOWN.
>> THIS ORDEAL HAS BEEN DESIGNED
TO CAUSE AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
STRAIN ON MY FAMILY.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF MOUNTING
LEGAL BILLS, AND LESS PERSONAL
ATTACKS DESIGNED TO CAUSE
MAXIMUM DAMAGE TO FAMILY AND
FRIENDS.
IT’S CLEAR THAT FOR THE FORCES
THAT OPPOSE US, THERE IS NO END
IN SIGHT.
I CANNOT ALLOW THOSE FORCES TO
CONTINUE TO CAUSE PAIN AND
DIFFICULTY TO THE PEOPLE THAT I
LOVE.
>> Bret: TODAY’S ANNOUNCEMENT
COMES EXACTLY TWO WEEKS AFTER
GOVERNOR GREITENS WAS FOUND NOT
GUILTY ON HIS FIRST CHARGE,
RELATED TO A PICTURE THAT HE
ALLEGEDLY TOOK AND TRANSMITTED
FROM HIS MISTRESS.
THAT PHOTO NEVER MATERIALIZED IN
THE STATE DROPPED THE CASE.
HE WAS ALSO CHARGED WITH FELONY
TEMPER AND TAMPERING OF A
COMPUTER RELATED TO MISUSING A
DONOR LIST FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES.
TODAY A JUDGE RULED THAT HE
WOULD HAVE TO TURN OVER
PAPERWORK RELATED TO THE SECOND
CHARGE, AND THIS VERY LONG SAGA
OF SCANDALS INVOLVING THE